après six films récents consacrés à
spider man l'homme araignée est de
retour au cinéma
ces postes un film d'animation et spider
man est plusieurs dans spider man new
generation de pop persichetti peter
ramsey et rod mais rotman plusieurs
super-héros arachnéen venus de
différentes dimensions se retrouvent
face à face aux côtes à côtes voir dos à
dos il ya un jeune spider man afro
américain qui vient brooklyn une spider
girl un dark spider man très pessimiste
et même un spider cochon
bref les trois auteurs s'amusent à
passer en revue tout ce que la bande
dessinée la télévision le cinéma jeux
vidéo ont fait avec le super héros
depuis 50 ans c'est très amusant simon
s'est non seulement amusant mais ces
virtuoses parce qu'il ya ces trois
réalisateurs qui sont brillants et
derrière eux il ya entre autres phil
lord et chris miller deux scénaristes et
réalisateurs à qui on doit notamment la
grande aventure légaux ou twendy one
jump street et sa suite
tempête de boulettes géantes bref des
type brillant qui fusent à toute allure
et je vais vous montrer qu'un petit
extrait comment ils sont capables de
manier l'abstrait et le concret la
référence le meta est une action
débridée
vous allez voir ça ce sont donc nos deux
notre spider man confirmer notre spider
man en herbe qui essaye de piquer un
truc on s'en tape dans un labo et là
vous allez voir tout d'un coup les
méchants ça devient une masse
indistincte à tous et surtout qui
sortent des âmes de partout qui leur
courent après et là on se retrouve dans
quelque chose on a à la fois un
enchaînement de plans à la fois décidé
de pure vd et des plantes qui se
transforme regardez là on les suivait
hop on est en plongée on est donc
j'ai là ça va se retourner et au nouveau
ça devient extrêmement fluide pourquoi
parce qu'on est collé aux sensations des
personnages graphique sétif sera pas
devant la fois capable de citer du jeu
vidéo comme boudier mais aussi le co
créateur avec stan lee le spider man à
savoir ce qu'il dit qu est la voix j'ai
vraiment l'impression d'être dans des
planches de marvel de la grande époque
du golden age et comics c'est un bonheur
absolu est toujours de s'interroger sur
comment est-ce que je filme un héros et
comment est-ce que je filme aéro il va
tout d'un coup découvrir ses pouvoirs et
bien comment est ce qu'ils découvrent
aussi pouvoir ce spider man la
problématique de spider man ça toujours
été d'être un ado qui veut devenir un
adulte ou un adulte qui galèrent dans sa
jeune vie des débats à l'assemblée deux
hivers il y rassemble sept ados qui ne
causent pas sauter équipe et moi je
compte le betis cours et l'adulte si si
je suis moi fais comme moi parce que
spider man c'est une question
identitaire est est ce que nous dit le
film de très jolies c'est qu'en réalité
tout le monde peut-être spider man essai
puis à la flexion à la fois sur les
films précédents les différentes
incarnations du héros mais sûre qu'est
ce que ça nous demande de nous dépasser
et comment est ce qu'on peut se
transmettre
échaudés voyez la caméra se pose quand
tous deux sont réunis dans le plan et
collaborent et apprennent l'un de
l'autre lui apprend qu'il a vieilli en
transmettant et l'autre à panda à
recevoir et là où le film à nouveau
alors là on devrait se poser normalement
doit avoir un petit peu de dialogues là
bas non ça va partir en cacahuète arrive
évidemment encore un autre ailleurs et
un spider girl tout est à nouveau à la
regarder on a ces plans sur réaliste
plastiquement c'est un bonheur absolu
la situation à spa de seconde
si fier et on arrive voilà tout nouveau
personnage qui va encore on va dire
faire encore avancer l'action et nous
proposer quantité de nouvelles choses
c'est un film qui aimait virtuose de
bout en bout
c'est absolument orgasmique à la havane
la remballe cela faisait longtemps qu'un
film de super-héros m'avait pas emballé
comme ses surprises mais oui c'est hyper
fun et puis alors le pari graphique
quand même est vachement audacieux ce
mélange de 3d 2d de mangas de comics on
a l'impression d'être dans un comics de
feuilles de feuilleter parfois carrément
la bd donc c'est très très fort jetons
que c'est une origine historique est
vraiment très innovante et une
réanimation du genre parce que c'est ça
qui s'opèrent véritablement une
réanimation du genre hyper inédite hyper
bien vu j'ai l'impression de devenir
vieux d'un non non j'ai adoré le film
est ce que je veux dire ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que j'ai l'impression
que c'était comme si j'avais commencé à
regarder des jeux vidéo dans les années
90 et que je regarde et soudain l'ailier
de 30 ans plus tard je découvrais
quelque chose je crois que c'est un des
trucs les plus contemporains que j'ai vu
un des trucs les plus neufs que j'aime
voir je trouve que y'a pas un moment
dans le film où je ne suis pas surpris
par ce qu'il fait pas recette par cette
façon de passer du jeu vidéo de passer à
la bande dessinée passer de la 2d à la
3d le passé à différents niveaux
il ya quelque chose aussi dans l'ironie
forme d'ironie nouvelle que je trouve
très intelligente constamment qui joue à
des dégrés de lecture incroyable et
surtout je trouve que le film est
constamment en train de s'emballer et
s'est jamais de la bouillie visuelle
on est tout le temps tout le temps en
mouvement toujours une échelle globale
de revoilà la vie tout à l'heure qui est
des personnages et de l'histoire c'est
vraiment très étonnant
marinette et ben je dis tout comme mes
copains j'ai six ont raison et alors
j'étais la première surprise de ce que
j'avais envie d'aller voir ça comme de
bouffer des limaces
non mais vraiment mais on s'est bien
marré ben oui ça va mais à l'heure et et
puis surtout va là où la virtuosité tout
ça mais le petit personnage à des gamins
il est formidable
son père est formidable v12 cette espèce
de pyjamas des gueux qui l'a en fait il
est allé acheter un costume de spider
man dans une boutique et un caméo dont
je vous dis rien mais qui est rigolo
comme tout est donc voila et donc on
joue là dessus sur la l'autre c'est un
héros des prix mais il a une espèce de
battre pyjama comme ça de chômeur
dépressif qui sortent plus de chez lui
je donne avec de là avec de la bedaine
mais ce personnage de
d'adolescents mais moi j'espère vraiment
y aura une suite en ré et puis pour
finir ça sort juste un an après black
panther et ça veut aussi dire des choses
quoi qu'on ait atteint un personnage à
l'afro américain c'est hyperimportant
quoi de voir un spider man qui lui aussi
fait ils ont inventé le nouveau spider
man à villeurbanne de maintenant est ce
que ce serait pas le meilleur spyder
jamais vu alors la saison pour ce genre
d'erreur à savoir en vie dure et que
miles morales est un personnage qui
existe dans les comics depuis un petit
moment ce pas une création du film mais
c'est très intéressant de croire que ces
gens du jour spider man new generation
de bob persichetti peter and zero denis
rodman c'est au cinéma en ce moment vous
allez grimper aux murs